this video is about the new report from
the intergovernmental panel on climate
change but before telling you about that
let me first tell you a brief story this
video is also sponsored by brilliant
more about them later
in 1963 a zoologist named robert payne
conducted an experiment in macor bay
washington pain removed from the bay all
individuals of a particular species of
starfish known to predate on mussels in
response as expected the muscle
population of makobe exploded but
something else interesting happened the
ecological diversity of the bay
collapsed of the 15 species present at
the start of the experiment only eight
remained at the end paine would go on to
describe the starfish as a keystone
species in macor bay a species that when
removed caused the rest of the ecosystem
to collapse scientists have subsequently
identified many other keystone species
such as gray wolves in yellowstone
national park and the snowshoe hare in
boreal forests science now understands
that the biosphere including need i
remind you humans is a vastly
interconnected web that is very durable
in some ways but in others is actually
very fragile the removal of just a
handful of species can cause the entire
system to collapse
so
with all that in mind
what does this document have to say this
is the sixth assessment report from the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change's second working group so the
first working group at the ipcc looks at
the physical basis of climate change
what's causing it and their latest
report was released late last year this
second group is concerned with the
impacts of climate change how it's
affecting humans and the world now and
how it will likely affect us in the
future what does this report say
well to oversimplify it says that
billions of people and a high proportion
of all species on earth
are being affected by climate change
already
those impacts include decreased food
security more extreme weather events
more widespread wildfires and changes in
rainfall patterns all things that we
have observed already the report also
says that by continuing to emit carbon
into the atmosphere today committing to
further warming in the future those
impacts will get worse and worse and in
fact will quite quickly get so bad that
we simply will not be able to adapt to
them but to stress that earlier point it
says that this isn't just a future
problem climate change is already
killing people
destroying nature
making the world
poorer
normally at this point in one of my
videos i'd put in a joke or i put in a
meme to try and lighten the mood about
how like i don't know the report sounds
like light reading
but um
this report is far too big and far too
important to be fully covered in a
youtube video like this so i'm going to
link to some other youtube videos in a
playlist up here on the screen and down
in the description that i would
encourage you to check out they're made
by very talented people looking at
different aspects of this report in this
video i want to focus on just one aspect
of this report to really drill into its
significance
i want to talk about the most
existential threat described by the
report
the impact of climate change on the
biosphere working group two's report
summarizes the state of current research
climate change has caused substantial
damage and increasing irreversible
losses in terrestrial freshwater and
marine ecosystems the extent of climate
change impacts are larger than
previously estimated and some losses are
already irreversible such as the first
species extinctions driven by climate
change while others are approaching
irreversibility
this is horrifying on its own but quite
apart from the horror of watching
climate change dismantle the natural
world destroy the beauty the
biodiversity
there is a greater danger
think back to the starfish in mako bay
the report states that between three and
fourteen percent of terrestrial species
will likely face very high risk of
extinction equivalent to being
critically endangered today at one and a
half degrees of warming at two degrees
of warming that increases to between
three and eighteen percent of species
at three degrees between three and
twenty nine percent of species the risk
of a species going extinct in a
biodiversity hotspot specifically such
as a coral reef or the amazon rainforest
is currently two percent a percentage
that will double if the world warms by
one and a half degrees and increase
tenfold if the world warms by three
degrees a scenario that is sadly
entirely possible the risk is that we
drive the starfish to extinction in
makoor bay and the gray wolves to
extinction in yellowstone and the
snowshoe hair to extinction in canada
and a whole host of species that we've
not even had the time to yet identify as
keystone species to extinction and cause
a cascade of ecosystems to collapse one
by one
by one
a mass extinction if that happens then
we are not separate from the biosphere
we are part of it in fact we are
completely dependent upon it for for
example our food production to quote the
report climate change will increasingly
put pressure on food production and
access especially in vulnerable regions
undermining food security and nutrition
global warming will progressively weaken
soil health and ecosystem services such
as pollination increase pressure from
pests and diseases and reduce marine
animal biomass undermining food
productivity in many regions on land and
in the ocean put simply if we increase
the risk of extinction across the board
we increase the risk of keystone species
going extinct making the collapse of
ecosystems around the world
more likely and if that happens
if they go we cannot feed ourselves
we go perhaps however this sounds like
speculation to you like any prediction
of the future it's difficult to take
seriously unless there's data unless
there are events in the past that mirror
what we are predicting for the future
unfortunately if we look at the fossil
record at times in the earth's past when
extreme climatic change happened
that is
exactly what we find i'm holly nanette
i'm a phd student in paleobiology and i
work on the responses of marine
organisms to climate stresses in the
past so there were five mass extinctions
in the last 450 million years so the
history of complex life on earth
something gets classed as a mass
extinction when the extinction rate is
significantly above the background rate
for example the permian triassic mass
extinction the mother of all mass
extinctions led to
a loss of between 80 and 90
of species in the marine realm and
between 75 and 80 percent of species on
the land out of the five big mass
extinctions we know definitely too
that were
rapid warming events they were caused by
the emission of vast amounts of
greenhouse gases into the atmosphere
much like what we're seeing today only
back before humans existed this emission
of greenhouse gases came from gigantic
volcanic provinces today it's us humans
and we're also much quicker at it than
the volcanic provinces were if you would
like to learn more about paleoclimate
that is climate in the past check out
the mini series that i made with paulina
and her colleagues linked in the
description one of the things we
discussed in that series was the
response of different species to warming
climates for ancient mass extinctions of
course we don't have the option to study
the changes within the organism's bodies
but we can see larger scale patterns we
see that species migrate pole words
during warming events they shift the
habitat away from the equator then
secondly some organisms also show a
decrease in the adult body size as a
response to increasing temperatures we
are seeing these responses today in fact
they are some of the strongest bits of
evidence we have that climate change is
already affecting life on earth the
working group 2 report notes that
approximately half of all of the
thousands of species studied showed
climate-related changes in their
territorial ranges moving pole words or
to higher altitudes to try and stay cool
enough what we are seeing today mirrors
past mass extinctions because
while certain organisms were able to
adapt to changes in their climate in the
past changes i should point out that
were far more gradual than what we are
seeing today adaptation was not the norm
extinction was the historical record
indicates that at our current
unprecedented rate of warming humans are
knowingly causing the sixth mass
extinction
in the history of earth
a study last year estimated that a total
global warming of 5.2 degrees celsius at
a rate of more than 10 degrees in a
million years would cause a mass
extinction on par with the big five for
context the current rate of warming that
humans are causing as measured over the
past century is approximately 17 000
degrees
per million years if we get to a warming
of 5.2 degrees celsius
it will result in a mass extinction that
is on the same scale as the ancient mass
extinctions that is even without the
other anthropogenic impacts like
deforestation and ocean acidification
the actual threshold is probably going
to be lower how do you feel looking at
stuff like the working group 2 report
knowing what you do how does current
changes make you feel
afraid
in talking about climate change it's
important to toe the line between
stressing the severity of the situation
and stressing that the problem is
solvable
i hope that what you've just seen in
this video has communicated to you the
severity of this situation
i know it can be difficult to believe
given a background of
wars and pandemics but
this situation is truly dire we are
looking at a human-caused mass
extinction reaching that balance of
severity and optimism is made especially
difficult because this working group 2
report isn't about what we can do to
mitigate and adapt to climate change
that's in the next report from working
group 3 due out sometime next month what
working group 2 does stress is that we
can do things and that while those
things may vary in effectiveness across
different regions the longer we leave it
to take action the less effective those
actions will be some of those actions
are to directly prevent species from
going extinct today something that
charities such as dural have been doing
for decades and now face unprecedented
strain some actions are to protect the
natural environment or to empower
marginalized communities to protect
their environment
but most importantly demand the
reduction of carbon emissions into the
atmosphere the report next month will
give details of how to most effectively
do this but ultimately it's going to
involve fundamentally rethinking how we
think of energy use and energy
generation the positive takeaway of this
report is that it's not too late by
taking action by demanding action and by
listening to the working group 3 report
that comes out next month we absolutely
can still avoid this future of mass
extinction and along the way we can make
the world a more just place in a
nutshell this report says that things
are worse than we thought that the
effects of climate change are here
now and that they will get worse in the
future the longer we delay
meaningful action
there's a very real risk of ecosystems
starting to collapse around us
soon
but
if we can limit
future warming and if we can limit it to
one and a half degrees celsius which is
a really big ask but just about possible
if we're super aggressive in cutting
emissions then we can limit the damage
and we can protect species
all over the world
there is
a narrow window of time
really
this decade in which we can still
stop this
i wouldn't be able to spend as much time
as i do on these videos and get these
messages out to such a broad audience
without the help of sponsors so please
do stick around for just a moment to
find out about brilliant who have kindly
sponsored this video brilliant is an
educational website and app that allows
you to learn scientific and mathematical
skills in a fun interactive way even if
you're not in full-time education these
skills are really valuable to learn the
reports the ipcc put out for example are
extremely condensed versions of
thousands of scientific papers and that
means they are very information dense so
unless you have some amount of
scientific or statistical literacy you
are dependent on journalists and people
like me to tell you what these reports
say having an understanding of
statistics for example unlocks a new
powerful way of looking at the world and
brilliant has a predefined learning path
of expertly written courses on
statistics featuring interactive
problems that get you to apply your
knowledge straight away rather than just
reading and regurgitating information or
if you prefer you could take their
courses on computer science or logic or
even relativity brilliant is also
constantly expanding their catalogue of
courses so whether you're a beginner an
expert or anywhere in between there's an
interactive lesson to help you
improve and learn to get started for
free and try out everything brilliant
has to offer visit brilliant.org simon
clark or click the link in the
description the first 200 of you will
also get 20 off brilliant annual premium
subscription thanks so much to brilliant
for supporting this video
thank you so much for watching the video
all the way through to the end if you've
never shared one of my videos before
then i would please implore you to share
this one this is why i have this
platform ultimately it's to try and
communicate research and especially
communicate research that has a positive
impact
that's this
that's this video if you've never shared
one before please now is the time thank
you so much to paulina for speaking to
me about her research again if you'd
like to see the mini series that we did
together i'll leave a link in the
description and there's also a link to
that playlist in the description of
other videos made about the report and
what it means by other talented
youtubers please do check them both out
if you would like to support dural and
the work that they do preventing species
from going extinct i'll also leave a
link in the description to their website
where there's lots more information
about the work they do if you're staying
on youtube here's some recommended
viewing next if you enjoy the video
please do pop a like and i'd like to
again implore you to please share this
one thank you again for watching and
i'll see you in the next one